[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Das heutige Video haben sich einige gewünscht.
Ich mache heute eine Kinder-Pinguí-Torte.
Die Kinder Pinguís haben die Küche noch nicht erreicht.
Ela ist gerade noch einkaufen.
Die holt sie.
Ich hoffe, die Kinder Pinguís kommen hier auch an.
Sie ist natürlich nicht alleine einkaufen.
Kinder Pinguí kennt ihr vielleicht aus dem Kühlregal.
Zur Info: Das Video ist nicht produktplatziert,
es wird nicht bezahlt, denn
ich mache ja das Produkt eigentlich wieder nach
sozusagen in Form einer Torte.
Ja.
Und zwar ist das aus dem Kühlregal,
hat zwei Schokobiskuitschichten,
in der Mitte eine helle Sahnecreme
und da in der Mitte noch eine Schokoladenschicht,
richtig schön knackig.
Und das Ganze mache ich jetzt als Torte.
Das heißt, die Basis ist zuerst ein Schokoladenbiskuit.
Da gibt es auch schon ein Grundrezept auf meinem Kanal.
Bei Biskuit muss man einfach immer nur beachten:
zwei Teile Eier, ein Teil Zucker, ein Teil Mehl.
Da es ein Schokobiskuit ist, ein bisschen weniger Mehl
und dafür noch Kakaopulver.
Also habe ich jetzt hier an Zutaten
fünf zimmerwarme Eier,
125 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Und jetzt habe ich hier noch Mehl und Kakao
und zwar 90 Gramm Mehl
und 35 Gramm Kakao.
Das war es schon.
Und im Prinzip sind es ja echt die Grundzutaten
Ei, Zucker, Mehl, Kakao.
Und die habe ich immer da
und kann jederzeit einen Biskuit zubereiten.
Jetzt gebt ihr die zimmerwarmen Eier hierein,
Zucker und Salz.
Dann Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Und jetzt rührt ihr die Masse
für mindestens zehn Minuten, besser noch 15,
mit dem Handrührgerät vielleicht sogar 20,
damit die Eier-Zucker-Masse richtig schön weißcremig wird.
Den Ofen auch schon mal vorheizen auf 180°C.
Tortenring bereitstellen
und losrühren.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Masse perfekt,
lange genug gerührt.
Jetzt kann ich hier Mehl und Kakao sieben.
Hm, ich habe Kakao gesagt,
nicht Kaka-o.
Habt ihr mir beigebracht.
Jetzt bin ich ein stolzer Kakaosager.
Und das jetzt auf jeden Fall sieben,
damit einfach keine Klümpchen
vom Kakao und vom Mehl überbleiben.
Und jetzt ganz vorsichtig unterheben,
am besten mit einem Schneebesen
von außen nach innen.
Aber, wie gesagt, da könnt ihr euch die Tipps
auch gerne noch mal im Basisvideo anschauen
zum Biskuit.
Ich hoffe, der wird jetzt dunkel genug,
aber ich glaube schon.
Es dunkelt ja im Ofen noch mal schön nach.
Denn Kinder Pinguí ist ja auch recht dunkel.
Dann direkt in den Tortenring füllen.
Ich habe jetzt hier übrigens den Biskuit
nicht auf 26 cm umgerechnet,
sondern der wird jetzt ein bisschen flacher.
Denn, wenn ich jetzt den normalen Biskuit nehme,
der ist einfach schön hoch
und dann aber zu hoch für die Torte, finde ich.
Denn in dem Original Kinder Pinguí
ist ja auch der Teig ein bisschen dünner.
Und daher soll jetzt auch die Torte eben
dementsprechend dünner werden.
Jetzt verteilen
und dann sofort im vorgeheizten Ofen backen.
[Musik]
Der Biskuit ist jetzt gebacken.
Die Pinguís sind jetzt hier auch angekommen.
Jetzt mache ich die Creme.
Aber ich zeige euch das jetzt mal kurz.
Die machen ja immer eine Milchcreme rein.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig dann zum Nachmachen.
Aber da steige ich dann auf Sahne um.
Also, wenn es die Diskussion gibt,
ob Milchschnitte oder Kinder Pinguí,
oh, bin ich Team Kinder Pinguí.
Josh, du?
>> JOSH: Ah...
>> SALLY: Oder doch Milchschnitte?
>> JOSH: Vielleicht auch eher Kinder Pinguí.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also wegen den Klitschko-Brüdern
würde ich schon sagen: Milchschnitte.
Aber so geschmacklich,
würde ich schon Kinder Pinguí
– und ich habe ewig kein Kinder Pinguí mehr gegessen!
Mmh!
Ist schon gut.
Ist schon sehr süß.
Also die Creme ist ja eher so eine kompakte Creme,
nicht so eine
lockere Sahnecreme.
Aber,
ich glaube, ich mache jetzt
– also normalerweise würde ich jetzt
eine kompaktere Mascarpone-Sahne-Creme machen.
Aber, weil ich nicht, dass die Torte so schwer ist,
mache ich eine Quark-Sahne-Creme.
Und hier ist auch kein Honig drin,
also nicht wie bei
– nicht wie bei der Milchschnitte.
Hier sind andere viele Dinge drin,
aber kein Honig.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt eine
Quark-Sahne-Creme.
Ich richte kurz die Zutaten
und dann rühren wir es an.
Den Kuchen habe ich, wie gesagt,
schon den Biskuit aus dem Ofen genommen,
habe ihn schon rausgelöst.
Der steht jetzt im Kühlschrank,
damit ich ihn gleich gut schneiden kann.
Und dann machen wir jetzt die Creme
und später noch die Schokoschicht.
Die sind schon immer so cremig.
Mh.
[Musik]
Für die Creme nehme ich
250 Gramm Quark,
50 Gramm Puderzucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
400 Gramm Sahne
und San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
So. Den Quark gebe ich jetzt hier in die Schüssel.
Also ich versuche jetzt, die Torte nicht so süß zu machen
wie die Kinder-Pinguí-Schnitte an sich.
Denn die ist mir schon
schon zu süß.
Also da verändert sich, glaube ich, auch der Geschmack,
je älter man wird.
Als Kinder verträgt man das echt noch ganz gut,
so die ganze Süße, den ganzen Zucker.
Aber jetzt so einen ganzen Riegel,
den würde ich, glaube ich, nicht mehr schaffen.
Das wäre mir einfach zu süß.
Ja.
Jetzt hier verrühren,
also Quark, Puderzucker und Vanille.
Dann die Sahne dazu geben.
Die sieht ein bisschen flockig aus,
aber es war so eine
– das ist halt so bei der Bio-Sahne,
da setzt sich das immer ab.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Die stelle ich jetzt kurz in den Kühlschrank
und werde mich schon mal
um die Schokoladenschicht kümmern.
Da bin ich gerade echt noch
– oh, ich habe noch Sahne am Finger.
Egal.
Handkur.
Da bin ich echt gerade noch ein bisschen am Überlegen.
Denn im Kinder Pinguí ist ja so eine Schokoschicht.
Die ist schön knackig.
In der Torte darf sie natürlich nicht zu knackig sein.
Es wäre schon geschmacklich cool,
aber dann beim Anschnitt
geht halt dann der Knack
und dann geht das Stück kaputt.
Ach, deswegen werde ich wahrscheinlich
mit Kokosöl und Sahne arbeiten,
dass einfach die Schokolade ein bisschen weicher wird,
aber trotzdem noch knackig bleibt
und die Optik eben schön wird.
[Musik]
Also die Sahne kocht jetzt.
Jetzt den Herd ausstellen,
die Schokolade dazu geben und einfach verrühren,
bis sich alles gut verbunden hat.
Da ich jetzt keinen Schneebesen habe,
nehme ich einen Löffel.
Das ist jetzt auch egal.
Die Resthitze, die Restwärme, die regelt das von alleine.
Da hinten holen sich die Jungs und Mädels Kuchen.
Mh?
Ihr wartet auf Schokokuchen, he?
Marcel, ich kenne dich doch.
Marcel, komm. Ich gebe dir Schokokuchen.
Bitte schön!
>> MARCEL: Danke schön!
>> SALLY: Das beantwortet doch die Frage,
wer immer alle Videos
– alle Videos isst?! –
alle Kuchen isst.
Nicht nur die Obstfliegen,
– okay, sie ist echt eklig,
egal –
sondern auch das Team.
Später – nicht? – nichts mehr übrig lassen.
>> MARCEL: Okay.
>> SALLY: So. Während die Schokolade jetzt noch schmilzt,
kann ich schon mal den Biskuit
– den habe ich ja schon rausgelöst.
Der war auch schon im Kühlschrank.
Jetzt kann ich ihn hier einmal stürzen,
um ihn von der Folie zu lösen.
Ui! Ist der schön!
Und jetzt halbieren.
[Musik]
Okay.
Jetzt nehme ich den unteren Boden,
setze ihn auf eine Tortenplatte,
auf eine Drehplatte.
Also das ist jetzt nicht der Boden,
sondern der Deckel, wie man sieht.
Den Boden, den nehme ich dann für obendrauf.
Es ist aber eigentlich egal,
weil beide Seiten wirklich schön glatt sind.
Tortenring drumherum.
Die Creme, die wiege ich jetzt ab.
Denn ich möchte, dass die untere Schicht
und die obere wirklich identisch sind.
Ich habe ungefähr etwas mehr als 700 Gramm Creme.
Und ich möchte ja noch was für obendrauf.
Also nehme ich vielleicht 300 Gramm.
Ich gucke mal.
Wenn es mir nicht reicht,
mache ich einfach noch mal eine Creme.
Mh, ich nehme 350 Gramm.
[Musik]
Und jetzt wirklich versuchen, ganz glatt zu streichen.
Und jetzt friere ich die Torte kurz ein,
damit die Sahneschicht einfach schön fest wird.
Die Schokolade ist ja sowieso noch ein bisschen warm.
Und dann kommt die Schokoschicht drauf.
[Musik]
Die Sahne wird mir nicht reichen.
Deswegen habe ich noch mal 100 Gramm dazu gegeben.
Also ich ändere dann das Rezept auf 500 Gramm Sahne
und dann passt es.
[Musik]
Die Torte ist jetzt angefrostet,
also schön kalt auf der Oberfläche.
Jetzt nehme ich die Schokolade.
Die kommt hier drauf.
Das ist jetzt wirklich die Kunst,
die schön glatt zu verstreichen
und gleichmäßig.
Das geht halt echt am besten mit Drehtellern.
Und am besten nicht ganz bis zum Rand.
Da lassen wir so einen kleinen Rand außen übrig,
so frei.
Ja, es hätte ein bisschen weniger sein dürfen.
Ach, vergesst den Rand.
Vergesst, was ich gesagt habe.
Wir machen es bis zum Rand.
Und jetzt kommt die Torte noch mal ins Gefrierfach,
damit die Schokoschicht fest wird.
Das ist ja jetzt wie so eine Art Ganache,
also schon ein bisschen weicher, die Schokolade,
nicht so knackfest wie eben die Zartbitterschokolade.
Was war das eben?
>> JOSH: Lustig.
>> SALLY: Das war so quak.
Egal.
Jetzt kommt die noch mal ins Gefrierfach,
wird schön fest.
Und dann kommt die Sahne noch mal obendrauf.
Also eigentlich geht die Torte echt recht schnell.
Man muss einfach nur diese Kühlzeit beachten.
Im Gefrierfach geht es schneller,
im Kühlschrank dauert es ein bisschen länger.
Aber den Tipp kennt ihr ja bereits.
Sie ist fest geworden, die Schokolade.
Mh.
Vielleicht hätte ich noch 20 Gramm Sahne
mehr machen müssen.
Egal.
Wir probieren es so.
Ich wollte den Knack,
also kriege ich einen Knack
– die Torte,
nicht ich.
>> JOSH: Stimmt.
>> SALLY: Ja, he.
Bei mir ist schon alles vorbei.
Da kann man nichts mehr retten.
Nichts mehr zu retten, Josh, oder?
>> JOSH: Es besteht noch ein Fünkchen Hoffnung.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also zweite Schicht.
Und die jetzt auch schön glatt streichen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich halt keine Creme mehr übrig für die Deko.
Also muss ich noch mal Creme machen.
Ei, ei, ei!
Und jetzt kommt der Biskuit drauf.
Ich drücke den jetzt ganz vorsichtig glatt
mit der Burgerpresse.
So. Das war es jetzt erst mal.
Jetzt darf die Torte noch mal in die Kühlung.
Und ich kann schon mal
die Schokolade vorbereiten für den Überzug.
Und das war es dann.
Also das ist dann die Torte.
Und ich decke die Torten immer gerne ab
mit einem Tortenretter, damit sie einfach nicht austrocknen,
vor allem der Biskuit an der Oberfläche
eben nicht austrocknet.
Ich glaube, ich stelle sie in den Gefrierschrank.
So.
Ich hacke jetzt hier mal Zartbitterkuvertüre
für die Deko außen.
Denn ich werde die komplette Torte mit Kuvertüre überziehen,
wie ein Kinder Pinguí
auch überzogen ist.
[Musik]
Die Kuvertüre, die teile ich jetzt.
Zwei Drittel davon erwärme ich jetzt nämlich direkt
über einem Wasserbad
und das restliche Drittel nehme ich zum Herunterkühlen.
Und ich nehme noch etwas Kokosöl dazu.
Bei uns ist es gerade echt warm hier in der Küche.
Deswegen ist das Kokosöl auch ganz flüssig.
Normalerweise ist das bei Raumtemperatur eher fest.
Aber bei uns ist Raumtemperatur gerade
26, 28°C?
Bestimmt, nicht?
>> JOSH: 29°C.
>> SALLY: Es ist schon richtig
– 29°C –
richtig warm.
Hier lasse ich das Wasser kurz kochen
und stelle dann den Herd aber aus.
So könnt ihr nämlich auch sichergehen,
dass kein Wasser in die Schokolade kommt,
dass sie nicht zu heiß wird.
Los! Los! Los! Los!
[Musik]
Wenn die Schokolade dann geschmolzen ist,
nehmt ihr sie direkt vom Herd herunter.
Und mit dem restlichen Drittel
werde ich sie jetzt herunterkühlen.
So hat die Kuvertüre gleich
die perfekte Weiterverarbeitungstemperatur,
hat einen schönen Glanz.
Deswegen macht man das,
die Impfmethode.
Ich impfe jetzt sozusagen
mit der festen Schokolade die flüssige Schokolade.
Und dann wird sie genau so, wie ich sie haben möchte.
Und jetzt einfach schön verrühren,
bis auch diese Schokolade jetzt geschmolzen ist.
[Musik]
Hier gebe ich jetzt noch das Kokosöl dazu,
damit die Kuvertüre beim Anschnitt einfach nicht so fest ist.
Ich habe ja auch die Sahnetorte drunter.
Also das muss schon ein bisschen geschmeidiger sein.
Und sie bekommt einen schönen Glanz dadurch.
Oh! Jetzt habe ich sie verschüttet.
Jetzt habe ich verschüttet.
Also man könnte jetzt auch noch Sahne dazu geben.
Dann wird es wie so eine Art Ganache
und man hat eine etwas festere Textur.
Ich probiere es jetzt einfach so.
Denn ich möchte, dass die Glasur glänzt.
Jetzt habe ich hier so ein Abtropfgitter
mit einem Pizzablech drunter.
Okay.
Und nicht mittig.
Egal.
Jetzt den Tortenring lösen.
[Musik]
Hier noch mal glatt streichen.
Und jetzt probiere ich es einfach.
Ich hoffe, dass die Kuvertüre am Rand hält.
Wenn nicht, kommt halt noch eine Schicht drauf.
Und los!
Auf los geht's los.
No risk, no fun.
[Musik]
Und die Kuvertüre, die zieht jetzt auch ziemlich schnell an.
Die Torte kommt in den Kühlschrank.
Ich setze sie jetzt hier auch gleich runter.
Ich warte noch ein bisschen, bis sie ein bisschen abtropft.
Und die Schokolade, die jetzt runtergetropft ist,
die könnt ihr natürlich weiter verwenden.
Ihr könnt Rocky Roads daraus machen.
Ihr könnt Cornflakes dazu geben
und so kleine Schoko Crispies machen.
Also auf jeden Fall nicht wegschmeißen.
Aber man muss natürlich immer
ein bisschen mehr schmelzen, als man braucht,
damit es eben auch schön drüberfließen kann.
Also packe ich die Torte jetzt
mit einem anderen Gefäß drunter
in den Kühlschrank.
Und dann fülle ich die Sahne,
die ich noch steif geschlagen habe, in einen Spritzbeutel
und dann wird fertig dekoriert.
[Musik]
So.
Leider bekam die Torte doch einen Grauschleier.
Aber was soll's.
Wir haben einfach Temperaturprobleme in unserer Küche.
Egal.
Ist halt so.
Okay. Ich hole kurz die Sahne.
Hä?
>> JOSH: Grauschleier.
>> SALLY: Keinen Grauschleier?
>> JOSH: Was ist falsch gelaufen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Entschuldigung, Josh.
Ganz ehrlich. Ich habe doch erklärt,
wie man keinen Grauschleier bekommt.
>> JOSH: Echt?
>> SALLY: Indem man diese Impfmethode macht,
diese zwei Drittel, ein Drittel
und dann noch Kuvertüre und dann noch...
>> SARAH: 30°C weniger, dann hätte es funktioniert.
>> JOSH: Hatte ich vorhin nicht dich gefragt, ob das so geht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und jetzt ist es doch falsch gelaufen.
Es war halt doch noch nicht die richtige Temperatur.
Ich habe aber auch, muss ich zugeben,
die zwei Drittel, ein Drittel nicht abgewogen.
Eigentlich bin ich da immer sehr genau.
Ich wiege es dann ab: 200 Gramm, 100 Gramm.
Ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich leider einen Grauschleier.
Und es nervt mich. Es nervt mich richtig!
Ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen,
wie sehr mich das gerade nervt.
[Musik]
Ich lasse es jetzt auch so,
weil ich mir so denke,
nee, das passiert bei euch vielleicht auch mal.
Wahrscheinlich kriege ich jetzt nur perfekte Torten von euch.
Dann bin ich stolz
und dann macht es mich noch mehr traurig,
dass mir das jetzt passiert ist.
Egal.
Ich lasse das jetzt so, Josh.
Und jetzt kommen hier so Sahnetupfer da drauf.
Die machen alles wieder okay.
>> JOSH: Da sieht doch die Welt
wieder gleich ganz anders aus.
>> SALLY: Da sieht die Welt gleich wieder ganz schön aus.
[Musik]
Und ich meine, wenn ihr die Torte nachmacht,
ihr braucht ja die Pinguí jetzt nicht unbedingt für die Deko.
Also ihr könnt ja auch eine Kinder-Pinguí-Torte machen
ohne Pinguí.
Aber so für die Deko,
dann sieht man gleich, was es sein soll.
Und ich fahre hier immer dann einmal so zack drüber
und schabe die Sahne weg.
Warum lacht ihr?
Lacht ihr mich aus?
>> SARAH: Wie du das gerade mit dem Finger gemacht hast!
>> SALLY: Ich habe es mit dem Finger probiert.
Das ging halt nicht.
Sorry.
Ich bin auch nur ein Mensch.
>> SARAH: Was? Echt?
>> SALLY: Hat sie das gesagt?
Ja, ich habe Tim Bendzko den Song geschrieben.
>> SARAH: Ich bin doch keine Maschine.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich bin doch keine Maschine!
Ich bin ein Mensch aus Fleisch und Blut.
Und ich will backen
bis zum letzten Atemzug!
Ich bin ein Mensch mit all meinen Fehlern,
mit dem Grauschleier und der
Sahne!
Ich bin keine Maschine.
Ich lebe von Zucker und Mehl,
von Zucker und
Butter, aha!
Aha!
Im Zeugnis würde stehen:
"Sie hat sich stets bemüht."
Doch sie hat Wein gepredigt und Wasser getrunken.
Oder geht das andersrum?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Sie hat gepredigt, wie der Grauschleier nicht geht,
und hat ihn dann doch hinbekommen.
Aber so ist es nun einmal.
So ist das Leben
von Sally,
29.
>> SARAH: Zu spät jetzt.
>> SALLY: Früher war sie einmal Lehrerin.
Heute
dreht sie durch.
Deswegen, liebe Kinder
– ich bin noch nicht fertig, Josh.
Ich bin noch nicht fertig, Josh.
Ich weiß, du wolltest mich gerade bremsen.
Aber nein.
Deswegen, liebe Kinder, lernt was Anständiges,
werdet keine Influencer.
Ihr seht, wo es endet.
Beim Grauschleier.
Jetzt bin ich fertig.
[Musik]
Wir probieren jetzt die Torte.
Murat darf testen.
Ich habe das Messer ein bisschen angewärmt.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Und das ist eine?
>> MURAT: Kinder-Torte,
Kinder-Pinguí-Torte,
Pinguin-Torte.
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Eine Kinder-Pinguí-Torte.
Eigentlich wäre...
>> MURAT: Oh, ich habe den Teller vergessen.
>> SALLY: Nee, ich habe ihn.
>> MURAT: Und das ist so ein Ding,
ich glaube, das mag auch jeder, oder?
Oder gibt es irgendjemanden...
>> SALLY: Ich hoffe es.
Oder meinst du Kinder Pinguí jetzt?
>> MURAT: Kinder Pinguí, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Das ist so...
>> SALLY: Ich habe vorhin nur gesagt,
als Kind isst man halt irgendwie süßer
und als Erwachsener
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: ein bisschen weniger, zumindest ich.
>> MURAT: Und, wie gesagt, das isst man ja nicht immer.
Das ist so eine tolle Geburtstagstorte,
wo sich jemand vielleicht wünscht,
oder mal zu einer Party oder so was.
>> SALLY: Puh!
>> MURAT: Aber das ist
– du hast die Torte jetzt so gemacht,
also du hast die Pinguine nur zu Dekozwecken genommen,
>> SALLY: Deko.
>> MURAT: aber die Torte schmeckt
genau wie ein Kinder Pinguí?
>> SALLY: Ich denke, nicht genau.
Also zum einen will ich es nicht so süß haben.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Das wollte ich nicht. Weil das ist schon süß,
so ein Riegel.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Aber es sieht optisch genauso aus.
>> SALLY: Ich meine, ganz gleich geht nicht,
weil das ist ja eine Milchcreme
und du kannst so jetzt keine Milchcreme
ohne Pulver und so weiter...
Aber so sieht es schon aus
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: wie ein Kinder Pinguí.
Dann gehe ich immer einmal mit dem Messer so drüber
und dann
>> MURAT: Aber ich muss sagen, das sieht genau gleich aus.
>> SALLY: ist das auch schön sauber.
>> MURAT: Josh, guck mal kurz her.
>> SALLY: Schon.
Ja.
>> MURAT: Sieht eigentlich eins zu eins gleich aus.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Dreh mal zu mir rüber,
so, dass man noch den Vergleich hat.
>> SALLY: Sieht schon gleich aus.
>> MURAT: Es sieht eins zu eins gleich aus, oder?
>> SALLY & JOSH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Jetzt muss ich doch auch probieren.
Mh?
>> MURAT: So.
Also...
Hm.
Schmeckt wie Kinder Pinguí.
Ja.
So.
Jetzt weiß ich, wie das Kinder Pinguí schmeckt.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Jetzt gucke ich mal, wie deins schmeckt.
>> SALLY: Alle waren so:
"Hat er ein Sandwich draus gemacht?"
>> MURAT: Hm.
Ja, es schmeckt wie Kinder Pinguí, nur nicht so süß.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Und durch den Quark
>> MURAT: Hm.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: ein bisschen leichter, gell?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oh, das ist echt gut,
>> SALLY: muss ich echt sagen,
auch mit der Schokolade.
>> MURAT: Das ist echt nicht so süß, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und durch den Biskuit richtig locker.
>> SALLY: Komm, iss es wie ein Sandwich!
>> MURAT: Ja, ich habe mir das als Kind
schon immer gewünscht. Ohne Spaß!
Ich wollte erst mal so eine richtig große Milchschnitte haben
und zwar so eine Milchschnitte, die ich so tragen muss,
die ich dann so essen kann.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und...
Boah!
>> SALLY: Echt gut.
Also probiert die Torte gerne aus.
>> MURAT: Boah!
>> SALLY: Ich habe ja auch schon viele Torten
dieser Art gemacht, wie die
– weißt du noch? Diese Bounty-Torte.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die war auch richtig gut, mit Kokos.
>> MURAT: Ich habe irgendwann mal die Angst,
dass du angezeigt wirst.
Von irgendeinem Konzern wirst du mal angezeigt,
weil du Sachen kopiert hast.
>> SALLY: Von einem Konzern nicht, vom HSV vielleicht.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht, weil ich mal
eine Trikottorte gemacht habe.
>> MURAT: Hm. Müssen wir die Geschichte erzählen?
[Musik]
Müssen wir die erzählen?
>> SALLY: Ja. So. Heute erzähle ich euch die Geschichte.
Ich glaube das nicht!
Ich kenne mich ja mit Fußball null aus.
>> MURAT: Also pass auf.
>> SALLY: Dann wollte ich...
>> MURAT: Warte ganz kurz. Du musst die Geschichte
und zwar als Ding...
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Also das ist eine unglaubliche Geschichte!
>> SALLY: Das ist wirklich eine unglaubliche...
>> MURAT: Ihr glaubt die gar nicht. Es ist wirklich passiert.
>> SALLY: Die muss ich euch heute erzählen.
Okay. Also...
>> MURAT: Erst mal die Frage:
Was glaubt ihr?
Von wem wurde Sally angezeigt?
Also ist es A
Coppenrath und Wiese,
weil sie so oft Coppenrath und Wiese kopiert hat?
>> SALLY: Hm. Ist es B Ferrero kinder?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder Oetker?
>> MURAT: Oder Oetker?
Oder ist es der HSV?
HSV sagt euch was?
>> SALLY: So.
>> MURAT: Was sagt der HSV?
>> SALLY: Kommt. Ratet mal. Wer hat mich angezeigt?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Wisst ihr das?
HSV heißt?
Weißt du, was HSV heißt?
>> SALLY: Habe ich da Oetker gehört?
Nein, er war es nicht.
Habe ich Coppenrath...
Mhm, war es auch nicht.
Habe ich da Snick-
Nee, die waren es auch nicht.
>> MURAT: Es war...
Es war der HSV.
>> SALLY: Es war der HSV.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt ein ganz kurzer Exkurs in die Geschichte.
Ich habe vor einigen Jahren
– vor fünf, sechs, sieben Jahren,
da war mein Kanal echt noch klein, also wirklich klein.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Da hatte ich vielleicht 100.000 Abonnenten,
also wirklich, wo ich sage: "Hey, komm.
Schon Reichweite, aber ganz wenig."
Dann habe ich unserem Bürgermeister, dem Walter Heiler,
den ich gerade herzlichst grüße,
– lieber Walter, wir müssen uns mal wieder sehen.
Da habe ich dem Walter Heiler
eine Geburtstagstorte gemacht.
Und der Walter Heiler ist wahrscheinlich
der einzige Mensch auf der Welt, der HSV-Fan ist.
>> MURAT: In Waghäusel auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Also in Waghäusel gibt es keinen HSV-Fan, nur...
>> SALLY: Ich wusste nicht mal, was HSV ist.
Also bis zu dem Zeitpunkt.
>> MURAT: Hundesportverein haben wir immer gedacht.
>> SALLY: Habe ich gedacht.
Ich habe gedacht, das wäre echt ein Hunde-
– HSV, Hundesportverein.
Egal.
Ich habe dann gegoogelt, habe gefunden: HSV,
so ein Logo, ein Trikot.
Und dann habe ich dem Walter
zum 60. Geburtstag das Trikot gebacken.
Und ich hatte nicht mal eine eigene Küche.
Da waren wir gerade im Umzug.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und das Küchenstudio hat zu spät geliefert
und ich musste im Küchenstudio
die Torte backen.
Dann habe ich die dem Walter übergeben.
Er hatte eine schöne Geburtstagsparty.
Und dann...
Das war es also.
>> MURAT: Und vor ungefähr zwei Monaten
kam vom Rechtsanwalt ein Brief
vom Rechtsanwaltsbüro,
das die Rechte vom HSV,
also vom Hamburger Sportverein, vertritt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und da stand drin,
>> SALLY: Dass ich angezeigt werde.
>> MURAT: ob wir eigentlich die Rechte hätten,
eine HSV-Torte zu machen,
also Sally hat aus Fondant
das Logo, die Raute vom HSV nachgemacht
und ob wir die Rechte dafür haben.
Dann haben wir gesagt: "Nee, natürlich haben wir sie nicht.
Wir haben ja nur eine Torte gebacken.
War ja nichts Besonderes.
Es war eine kostenlose Torte für den Bürgermeister."
Genau.
Und was war das Ende vom Lied?
Der HSV...
>> SALLY: Ich habe das, ehrlich gesagt, sogar
schon wieder vergessen gehabt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich habe gedacht: "Hä, HSV? Warum?"
>> MURAT: Dann behauptet das Anwaltsbüro,
dass wir,
dass du dir die Strahl-
– hört mal zu.
Der HSV spielt übrigens in der 2. Liga
seit
drei Jahren. Oder sind es zwei Jahre?
>> MARCEL: Ich glaube, es sind drei.
>> MURAT: Drei Jahre sind es schon?
>> MARCEL: Ja, ja.
Es könnte aber dann auch länger so bleiben.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Auf jeden Fall spielen die in der zweiten Liga.
Und da stand dann im Brief als Begründung,
die Sally würde die Strahlkraft des HSV benutzen,
um groß zu werden.
>> SALLY: Ich habe bis dahin noch nie was von denen gehört.
>> MURAT: Lieber HSV,
es gab mal Zeiten
von Thomas von Heesen, Uwe Seeler,
Didi Beiersdorfer,
das war eine richtig coole Zeit beim HSV,
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Aber das ist echt der Hammer. Ohne Spaß.
Jetzt sollen wir dieses Video,
das fünf Jahre alt ist,
sollen wir jetzt...
>> SALLY: Da wollten die, dass ich es lösche.
>> MURAT: Dass wir es löschen.
So.
Weil die Sally ja natürlich eine HSV-Torte gebacken hat.
Also ich würde es verstehen,
wenn sich der Bayern München meldet.
Wobei, das wäre auch furchtbar.
Dortmund oder, oder, oder, oder
was weiß ich, ein anderer Verein,
Borussia Mönchengladbach.
Es gibt Tausende von Dortmund-Torten im Internet.
Aber bitte macht niemals eine HSV-Torte!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Oh, der HSV.
Ja, hallo.
Ist hier der Marcell Jansen?
Marcell, ich habe gerade keine Zeit.
Ich rufe dich später wieder an.
So.
Auf jeden Fall, das war gerade Marcell Jansen.
Alles okay.
Der hat eh keine Ahnung, der Typ.
So.
Auf jeden Fall hat mich gerade der Marcell Jansen angerufen.
Aber wie auch immer.
Das ist eine krasse Geschichte.
Also wirklich, dass ein Sportverein anruft
und sich beschwert,
weil eine Grundschullehrerin aus Waghäusel
eine Torte, eine HSV-Torte gebacken...
>> SALLY: Vor fünf Jahren.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Das nächste Mal, wenn wir eine HSV-Torte backen,
dann müssen wir erst mal
wahrscheinlich Geld an den HSV bezahlen,
ob das in Ordnung ist, oder?
>> SALLY: Ah, wir hätten denen einfach das Video
– ah, die Werbekosten alles mit...
Das wollten die.
>> MURAT: Also eine ganz krasse Geschichte!
Also Sally hätte viele Gründe, angezeigt zu werden
von irgendwelchen Herstellern,
weil sie irgendwas kopiert hat wie das hier zum Beispiel.
Aber dann meldet sich der HSV.
Das ist eine ganz krasse Geschichte.
Ich habe so lachen müssen.
Wir haben alle hier gelacht.
Ganz Waghäusel lacht.
Eine ganz krasse Geschichte.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Aber ich möchte nicht auf das Thema
weiter hinausgehen.
Der HSV ist in der 2. Liga...
>> SALLY: Wir wollen nicht drauf rumreiten.
>> MURAT: Wir wollen nicht drauf rumreiten.
Der HSV ist in der 2. Liga schon genug bestraft.
Und es hat dieses Jahr nicht geklappt.
Mh.
Karma.
Auf jeden Fall ganz liebe Grüße an den HSV.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht kümmert ihr euch
nicht um Grundschullehrerinnen aus Waghäusel,
sondern vielleicht um eure Sportler.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann...
>> MURAT: Ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen,
ich mag St. Pauli wirklich.
Ich mag St. Pauli ohne Ende.
Ich finde, St. Pauli...
>> SALLY: Wir wollten eigentlich St.-Pauli-T-Shirts bestellen.
>> MURAT: Ja. So ist es. St. Pauli ist ein cooler Verein.
>> SALLY: Mein Gott!
>> MURAT: Auch Dortmund ist ein toller Verein,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Aber eigentlich wollten wir
gar keinen Fußball auf dem Kanal.
>> MURAT: Wobei ich so was...
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe eigentlich
so was von Schalke 04 erwartet.
Ehrlich.
Ich als Dortmund-Fan habe so was von Schalke 04 erwartet.
>> SALLY: Ja, aber ich habe halt noch nie eine Torte gemacht.
>> MURAT: Aber nicht mal die haben das gemacht!
Ja, Wahnsinn.
>> SALLY: Ich habe halt noch nie...
Und der Walter wird auch der Einzige sein,
der sich so eine Torte wünscht.
Von daher gehört es eigentlich der Vergangenheit an.
>> MURAT: Lieber Walter, es tut mir leid,
das nächste Mal, wenn du eine Geburtstagstorte
vom HSV von uns bekommst zu deinem 60. Geburtstag
– wobei, er wird nicht mehr 60, oder?
Nein, wird er nicht mehr.
Auch zu deinem 65. bekommst du leider
keine HSV-Torte mehr von uns,
weil das gibt rechtliche Schwierigkeiten.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich backe dir dann eine Kinder-Pinguí-Torte.
Die haben nichts dagegen.
>> MURAT: Oder eine vom Wiesental.
Genau, vom Fußballverein Wiesental
kriegst du eine Torte von uns. Okay?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Also das zur Torte,
das zum Kopieren von Backsachen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Macht's gut!
>> SALLY: Macht's besser!
>> MURAT: Und
St. Pauli.
>> SALLY: Ihr dürft übrigens meine Torten kopieren.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Macht sie gerne nach.
Und postet sie.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe auch nichts dagegen.
>> MURAT: Bye!
Liebe Grüße an alle Dortmund-Fans gehen raus.
>> SALLY: Tschüssi!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Wahnsinn! Ich habe eigentlich immer gedacht,
Bayern München meldet sich oder irgendjemand.
Irgendjemand.
>> SALLY: Ja, irgendwie...
>> MURAT: Und dann kommt irgendwo der HSV
aus der Ecke gekrochen.
Das ist nicht normal, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja. Ja. Ja.
>> MURAT: Das ist so zum Lachen eigentlich!
Und dass es genau die sind, meine ich,
das ist der Wahnsinn.
>> SALLY: Das ist der Wahnsinn.
[Musik]